oh
there's something in my beard by odin's
beard
thor odin's son
so thor odin's son is the norse god of
thunder and like how his name would
suggest he is the son of odin borsun who
was his name was justice the son of bor
bury son who is his name would suggest
is the son so thor lived in asgard
alongside the pantheon of norse gods
living his life fighting fierce battles
drinking the finest mead and uh all
right thor has arrived for the orgy and
so after years of this thor starts to
get a bit too big for his britches and
odin decides it's time to step in and
actually be a father father why have you
summoned me thor
i've seen with thine twitter posts but
father tis in vogue to ratio thy mortals
with the heat it takes enough away you
fool
hark the dreaded embrace of cancel
culture so odin banishes thor to earth
stripping him of his godly powers and
his memories in the hopes that the young
god will learn humility thor now lives
as donald blake a physically disabled
doctor a man who instead of wielding the
power of thunder treated the sick the
downtrodden and truly understood what it
meant to be human and then donald blake
is assaulted by an alien invasion during
his vacation to norway go to norway they
said it will be fun they said in order
to evade capture blake ducks into a cave
to hide from the invaders but as he does
the entrance collapses leaving him
trapped inside
however while in the cave he finds a
secret entrance in which he discovers
a stick oh come on in his frustration
blake slams the stick into the cave wall
and then suddenly he becomes the mighty
thor holy [ __ ] i'm hot at least that's
what the hammer says huh what's a
convenient plot exposition and so
wielding the power of the norse god of
thunder donald blake wards off the alien
invaders and begins protecting the world
as thor though while thor is on earth he
has some baggage he left behind in
asgard now thor was the favorite child
which left his little brother loki the
god of mischief living perpetually in
his shadow
stupid thor with his stupid muscles and
his stupid handsome face yeah this left
a bit of a chip on his shoulder so loki
lives up to his namesake and decides to
cook up a bit of mischief on earth for
my first act of tomfoolery i shall turn
the hulk into a clown
[Music]
hulk is at his limits to put a stop to
loki's shenanigans thor teams up with
the earth's mightiest heroes and ant-man
in order to bring loki down
no
defeated by the power of friendship
you know we make a pretty good team yes
you could say we really
avenged them out there
[Music]
now things are going well for a while as
donald blake juggled both his life as
the mild mannered doctor and the
beefcake superhero however odin
eventually calls thor back and welcomes
him back to asgard restoring the
memories of his past life
my son
are you all right
do you
remember
father
i
so now thor was once again fully himself
having discarded the identity of donald
blake and living as a protector of not
only earth but all of the nine realms
now for thor's powers
well uh
he's a literal god he's strong fast
tough he can shoot energy fly he's
mostly immortal and can speak every
single language ever buenos dias jen
foster
but then there's thor's hammer mjolnir
mjolnir is
interesting to say the least the hammer
gives you essentially all of the
abilities of thor but only if you can
pick it up and mjolnir is kind of like a
cat not just anyone can pick it up
damn it mjolnir you are going to the vet
and that's
that
now i just need to
no
but bad mjolnir yeah you can only pick
up the hammer if you are
worthy but being worthy enough to wield
thor's hammer is a pretty low bar first
there was beta ray bill who stole the
hammer from thor and then he and thor
had a slap fight in front of odin to see
who got to keep it
from there the registry of people who
picked up thor's hammer includes captain
america loki jane foster
squirrel girl venom hawk is that tom
hardy
conan the barbarian 90s glam rock thor
yeah
red hulk some random farmer captain
america again but problematic this time
magneto wonder woman superman
frog picked up thor's hammer
so yeah lifting thor's hammer isn't
quite as special as it used to be but on
the flip side mjolnir can also decide
that you aren't worthy
come on
remember consent is key but thor's time
as a hero has had its ups and downs
thor does battle with the entire gamut
of divine deities loki hella certain
hercules he's thrown down with
juggernaut oh i'm the juggernaut
well uh i'm thor odin's son uh
he's thrown the world serpent he's
thrown hands with cosmic beings the only
celestial mine i see
is this celestial ass kicking
so yeah thor stayed pretty busy so busy
in fact that jane foster his girlfriend
at the time decided enough was enough
thor i want a divorce what and yeah he
took that pretty bad
but for the most part things were going
pretty well for thor until
ragnarok the prophecy which foretells
the end of asgard
loki leads an army of trolls and orcs
against his asgardian brethren thor is
forced to watch as the forces of asgard
are torn asunder by loki's armies
mjolnir is broken and thor's comrades
fall
one by one thor is left broken and
defeated but then he discovers the well
of mimir and the power
of the runes following in his father's
footsteps thor sacrifices his life to
the well of amir hanging himself from
the world tree to take into himself the
infinite knowledge of the universe he
learns that ragnarok is a forever
repeating cycle and in order to finally
break it he must defeat those who sit
above in shadow and so ascending to a
level of godhood surpassing even his
father rune king thor sets forth on his
warpath to end ragnarok he also rips off
loki's head and kinda just carries it
around oh hey i've played lollipop
chainsaw from here thor's warpath brings
him to the world tree where by using the
full power granted to him by the runes
he wipes out the world tree alongside
those who sit above in shadow
sacrificing the asgardians and putting
an end to the perpetual loop of death
and destruction but it's okay because
all the asgardians were actually just
reincarnated on earth and they were just
sleeping thor wakes up and then realizes
that he has to wake up all of his
buddies if he wants to bring asgard back
so he begins traveling the world waking
up his homies and then builds a new
asgard in oklahoma zoning laws can kiss
my ass he also kicks the [ __ ] out of
iron man
didst thou think i was going to be okay
with you cloning me yeah don't worry
about the details from here thor is
kinda all over the place he fights the
living embodiment of super atheism why
couldn't love and thunder be good it's
just not
why not you stupid bastard he loses his
hammer his former girlfriend starts
using it and then she ends up dying of
cancer the universe ends and then it
unends thor becomes king of asgard he
becomes a herald of galactus galactus
you must stop
silence tis time for brunch
[Music]
i
i can still hear their screams suffer
wanna
get some ice cream buddy
thor is
a comic book version of the ship of
theseus he's the kind of character that
has to constantly adapt and evolve to
survive with the times unlike a
character like superman or batman or
even captain america or iron man he's
had to go through so many changes to
truly stay relevant from being a man's
tribute to norse mythology to space
faring explorer to 80s glam rock god
thor's worn a multitude of identities
over the years and to be frank i feel
his lack of timelessness makes him
timeless
in his own way
i haven't actually thought of uh the
post credit thingy yet ah
we'll get there i i promise
something will happen
hopefully this isn't what i end up using